cerca de la medianoche y luego de más de
12 horas de discusión en la cámara de
diputados quedó finalmente rechazada la
iniciativa de reforma constitucional que
envió el presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador esta iniciativa pretendía dotar
a la estatal comisión federal de
electricidad de todo el control sobre
toda la industria eléctrica y daba una
participación de mercado del 54 por
ciento a esta empresa del estado con el
objetivo de acuerdo con el presidente de
salvaguardar así la soberanía energética
no obstante al partido en el poder
morena y sus aliados no les alcanzó la
votación de las dos terceras partes
requerida para aprobar esta reforma
constitucional durante la sesión
legislativa maratónica predominaron los
descalificativos los diputados de morena
y sus aliados acusaron a los opositores
de ser traidores a la patria por
favorecer dijeron los intereses de
empresas particulares nacionales y
extranjeras en contraste los diputados
de la oposición aseguraron que no iban a
aprobar una iniciativa regresiva que
favorecía el monopolio excesivo del
estado y propiciaba la generación de
energías sucias el presidente lópez
obrador desde la tarde anticipándose a
esta derrota legislativa envió lo que
considera es su plan ve una iniciativa
de cambios a la ley minera para
salvaguardar así que sea el estado el
único facultado para explotar el litio
un mineral estratégico será este mismo
lunes cuando los diputados discutan esta
iniciativa de ley que a diferencia de la
reforma constitucional no requiere la
votación de las dos terceras partes de
los diputados presentes